oh now you're gonna want attention it's
like I know that you're a dog but I know
you can tell when I'm making a video are
you offended by that - see you guys know
look this thing it's like you know what
I'm gonna shoot a video okay now you
want to have this fight on camera also
this sandal is my mosquito killing
sandal yeah goose I'm gonna tell him
about it
oh there's one minute right now there's
a mosquito on the ceiling it's time to
go to battle missed it
hire me for your casual murders hello
welcome to this video my name is grace
Helbig if you didn't know look we all
have lots in life and your lot sucks a
lot I'll tuck you away like my feelings
what is this video about you ask great
question I don't know oh no my tumblr I
feel like I've been just really really
busy lately and I hadn't had a chance to
actually like talk to you guys and ask
you what you like to watch and a lot of
you said that you wanted to see a stream
of consciousness video so that's what
I'm doing today it just so happens that
those are one of my favorite types of
videos to shoot am I am i loving it yes
just you guys know this is a different
room in my house I'm not at some weird
Pinterest savvy kidnappers place I just
gave myself credit for being Pinterest
savvy I'm not at all I just got really
crafty this weekend because sometimes
when I have a lot of responsibilities to
do I avoid all of them by making very
average art I've done it my whole life
if I feel really stressed out I will buy
some canvases and paint
I'll make some bracelets I'll get some
plastic lemons put them in a lamp for
those diehard daily grace it's grace
fans look what now has a place in my
home hi mom this isn't my mom for anyone
that doesn't know me no no no my mom
just made this as an adult and I got it
for Christmas I was I got my hair done
here's a fun story when I got back to
Los Angeles my water pressure was weird
and a handyman come over today to look
at it and the water pressure was
mysteriously totally fine and he asked
when the last time I actually showered
was and I was like oh yeah Tuesday so I
showered tonight because I got one of
these industrial looking metal letters a
letter that it's the first letter of my
name because I'm basic literally no
other reason everyone has this now I
also have this I'm part I'm part of
something I cracked my phone like a bird
dying in front of you great omen
I bought this wooden sign at Michael's
and I spray painted it silver goose
please just let me have this did you
know you can't change your life by
trying to cover up all the bad with
spray paint you lied to me Michaels I
don't even know what's happening on the
internet what are the latest memes also
what are the latest words why don't we
come up with a word tuna is a phrase I
use to say when things are cool or good
there is a shore was a show on discovery
called wicked tuna about these guys that
were tuna fishermen in Boston and so I
just started saying wicked tuna in my
everyday speak as a term of excitement
can we make that a thing how would you
describe this video tuna what do I think
about your outfit today tuna hey I saw
your hustle out there in the sports
field that was real tuna get on the tuna
train or drive your Prius
everywhere the grace Helbig show
premieres on e at 10:30 p.m. on April
3rd following the soup we start our
first shoots for it tomorrow and I'm so
being excited I gotta hang out with
everyone this week and go over ideas for
the show it's gonna be so stupid fun I
can't wait for you guys to just be
stupid with me on television this is
like our private little weird down but
now we get to like go hang out in that
space like all the cool kids hang out in
and and be awkward there it's like when
you show up to prom in a duct-tape dress
and everyone's like about it but you're
like we're the duct-tape dress of
television is Brad Pitt doing anything
cool what's Shia LaBeouf done be normal
for a second what's happening didn't get
it that bugs reflex is real tuna
Alexander Skarsgard is
where I went off on a tangent by myself
but I'll let you guys know that the
tangent led me to a place where I think
the best stripper name might be Cristina
scars and then your nickname would be
tiny scars Oh God dumb idiot
I'm just a human butthole full of bread
pudding I am stupid I'm gonna be on
Jimmy Fallon this week I mean not I'm
gonna be on his show not on him in a
physical who knows no I'm not going to
do that because at this point they could
probably still revoke me being on the
show I'm going to be on The Tonight Show
with Jimmy Fallon on Wednesday and I am
so excited it's the first thing like
that that I'm doing and here's the
kicker it's me and Mitt Romney that
dream team should I say the fever dream
team so please tune in so that I can
feel like not awful about it okay that's
it right that's it yes that's it yes
that's it yeah okay can't believe I
forgot to say this while I was actually
shooting the video but I don't know hey
you're not the worst